[Musik]
österreichs Nationalteam im American
Football hat am Samstag dem 28 Oktober
23 erstmals em Gold geholt die
Österreicher stehen vor knapp 6500
Zuschauern zum dritten Mal in einem m
Finale die AFB Auswahl setzt sich in St
Pölten im Endspiel gegen Finnland mit
28:0 durch 13 Nationalspieler der
erfolgreichen
europameistermannschaft sind oder waren
Angehörige des
heresportzentrums sie können dank der
sportlichen Unterstützung des
Bundesheeres den Grundstein für den
Titel Gewinn
[Musik]
legen Verteidigungsministerin Claudia
Tanner zeigt sich über den großartigen
Erfolg sehr
erfreut Football ist ein militärisches
Spiel und wir gehen dorthin ab wo die
jungen sportlichen Menschen sind die wir
auch brauchen als Dienstgeber die
brauchen wir für die Zukunft und daher
gibt's keine bessere Verbindung wir
müssen und wir wollen Flagge zeigen
genau an solche
[Musik]
Orten
[Applaus]
gratulieren
gratulation